la neige tombée en abondance ces
derniers jours ne fait pas que des
heureux en plaine mais elle fait le
bonheur des stations de sports d'hiver
même les petites stations de basse
altitude elles ont un taux d'enneigement
exceptionnelles et pour la plus grande
joie des touristes des commerçants c'est
le cas en auvergne et dans les
alpes-maritimes carine azzopardi
la bourboule dans le massif central deux
mètres cinquante en haut des pistes pour
cette petite station un tel enneigement
et exceptionnel alors ici tout le monde
a le sourire
j'ai tombé vraiment au bon moment en
quantité les conditions sont vraiment
optimales et nous avons beaucoup de
demandes actuellement depuis le début du
mois les pistes ne désemplissent pas à
la clientèle est familiale et outre le
ski de descente beaucoup choisissent la
promenade dans des endroits encore
préservée je suis père bien agréable
beaucoup de neige beaucoup de shay
en face à un public merveilleux de
manière là ça très bien bilan 80 7 % des
commerçants qui vivent de la montagne
sont satisfaits d'ores et déjà ils
savent que leur saison sera très
rentable
plus au sud sur les hauteurs de nice une
autre petite station fait son beurre
d'ordinaire le public se déplace plutôt
dans les grosses stations alpines cette
année il est resté sur place pour une
journée ou un week-end les chiffres de
fréquentation exploser cette année 80 %
de chiffre d'affaires en plus par
rapport à l'an dernier ça représente
plus de 40000 forfait ski alpin landu
donc sourire sur les remontées
mécaniques
sa pensée c'est dû en grande partie à la
météo bien sûr la neige est de très
bonne qualité cette année les deux tiers
du domaine ce qui est contournée g
résultats les commerçants se frottent
les mains 30 % de chiffre d'affaires en
plus neige neige naturelle pas de neige
au canon
j'en vienne c'est super la petite
station devrait investir dans de
nouveaux télésièges et espère doubler
ces chiffres de fréquentation l'année
prochaine